benedict is going to talk about a final
finite model theoretic view of
propositional complexity
allow me to uh just give
a little bit of an a bio of uh
benedict he's a phd student in eric
grill's group at auckland university
and he's going to present this work that
he actually did as part of his
bachelor's thesis
and he broadly works in the space of
descriptive complexity and
finite model theory so without further
delay
benedict please go ahead yes thank you
um
yeah so this is a talk about this um
paper that i did a few years ago with
iris
martinville and um
and as the title says um you know what
we did in this work was to establish
certain interesting connections between
finite model theory and propositional
proof complexity
and so what do these two fields have to
do with each other
so improve complexity um people study
proof systems
so sets of inference rules that allow to
refute
unsatisfiable and propositional formulas
and one main example of this is the
resolution calculus
and one is interested in the size or the
complexity of
refutations depending on the formula
that you're refuting
and in finite model theory at least in
this context we're interested in
the expressive power of fixed point
logics on finite structures
uh yeah and albert has already said a
bit about fixed point logic so
these are extensions of first order
logics first of all logic that allow um
yeah to express algorithms and iteration
and um yeah so when i say finite
structures you can always think of
graphs or colored graphs
or things like that um
and so how do we bring these two things
together
so it turns out that um actually these
two formalisms so
proof systems and fixed point logics can
mutually simulate each other
uh provided that we use a suitable
translation between the two
two worlds so we have to somehow
translate between graphs
and prepositional formulas and then the
simulation
preserves complexity so
that's why one of the main applications
of this is that now we can transfer
lower bound results
that are known already between the two
areas of research
um okay so the overview
of the paper and of this talk is
basically this so
the two proof systems that we studied
were the resolution calculus
and the so-called polynomial calculus
which is an algebraic proof system
and we related them to these um two
fixed point logics respectively
uh yeah and in the end i'll also tell
you something about the the lower bound
applications that i mentioned
so in particular how do we um how can we
use known lower bounds from finite model
theory
to also get lower bounds for proof
complexity
okay so let's start with the resolution
so this is probably
yeah quite well known um so this is a
standard proof calculus for
refuting unsatisfiable propositional
formulas
which are given in conjunctive normal
form so as a set of clauses
and cnf formula is unsatisfiable isn't
only if
the empty clause can be derived from it
using only this
resolution rule so we only have one
inference rule in this calculus
yeah and the rule says if you have two
clauses where in one of them you have x
and then the other one you have not x
then you can
unify the clauses and throw away the
conflicting electron
and this calculus is sound incomplete so
you can refute any unsatisfiable forms
are
but of course the refutation may be very
large in general because
if you always found it a short
refutation then the satisfiability
problem would be in p
or so so that can't be the case um
and so we want to measure the complexity
of a reputation somehow
and there are two let's say main
complexity measures
um one is the size of the refutation so
that's the total number of clauses that
you need
and there's also another way to measure
it namely you can look at the width
so that's the size of the largest clause
in a refutation okay so
so much for resolution and
the logic that we related this to um is
least fixed for logic
or lfp and uh yeah as already mentioned
um this is an extension of
classical first autologic by mechanism
to
express iteration um and this is done
using um so-called fixed point formulas
which look like this um
and yeah they have a free variable and
um
to express this fixed point iteration uh
we use a second order variable which is
r in this case and so this can take
as values subsets of the universe of a
structure
and then i'm evaluating a fixed point
formula means that we have to form this
this fixed point uh which is a yeah
a sequence of um subsets of the universe
and there is this update formula five
which says uh
how to update this fixed point in each
step so more precisely
the semantics is this so if we have
structure a
and an element a small a from the
universe
then this satisfies such a fixed point
formula if and only if this element a
is in the least fixed point of this
sequence
yeah so the sequence starts with the
empty set
as the value of r and then the value of
r i plus 1 is always
the set of all elements in the structure
which satisfy the update formula with
respect
to the previous stage of the iteration
and i'll also show you
an example in a minute and essentially
one can prove that
the sequence of sets that is defined in
this way is always monotonically
increasing
and at some point will always reach a
fixed point where it doesn't change
anymore
yeah um and that's the least fixed point
and so this
uh has well-defined semantics and
yeah can be used to express iteration
um yeah and the expressive power of this
logic is
somewhere between that of first order
logic and p time
so in particular all these fixed point
iterations will terminate after a
polynomial number of steps
um so when we relate this to um the
resolution calculus
it's already clear that we will not get
resolution in total but we can only
relate this to a fragment of resolution
where the proofs are guaranteed to have
polynomial size because otherwise
uh it's clear that we couldn't do proof
search in a p-time formalism
and um yeah to get a feeling for this um
yeah why there is this intuitive
connection between fixed point logic and
resolution we can now consider an easy
problem
uh as an example so um
yeah this is the reachability problem on
graphs so the input is just a directed
graph with two distinguished vertices s
and t
and the question is is there a path from
s to t
and it's yeah it's quite clear that this
cannot be expressed in first order logic
because there is no mechanism to
to express transitive closures um but in
least fixed point logic we can
express this by the sentence that is
depicted there
um so the idea is we use this um second
order variable r
to stand for the set of all vertices
which are reachable from s
um and the fixed point update formula
says
in each step we add 2r each vertex x
which is either
equal to s so that's the base case
or which has a predecessor that is
already in r
and it's quite clear i think that this
the fixed point of this formula is
exactly the set of original vertices
so the computation proceeds as follows
so we start with the empty set
then at first we add the vertex s
because that's the only one satisfying
the update formula
and then we proceed by always adding the
successors so
this fixed point iteration essentially
simulates some breadth first search
in graphs you know like this and then
this is clearly the fixed point because
you can't add anything more
and then you see okay t is in the fixed
point so the formula evaluates to true
um okay so that this is the the fixed
point logic view
on this problem um and now it uh
it turns out that in resolution um
what happens if you encode this problem
in resolution
is very similar and somehow directly
simulates this fixed point induction
um namely if we encode this
as a resolution problem the natural way
to do this would be
like this so we take a set of
propositional clauses
which is unsatisfiable if and only if
there is a path from s to t
and so we use for each vertex in the
graph
a propositional variable and the meaning
should be that
the variable must be set to one if it is
reachable from s
so this is in fact the whole formula
whose minimum model is the set of
original vertices
so for each edge we have such an
implication that says uh if the
predecessor is reachable then also the
successor is reachable
and in the end we have this not x t
which says um
yeah which is that so that the formula
is unsatisfiable if and only if t
is reachable and um now the interesting
thing is if we
review this formula in the resolution
calculus
then somehow this resolution proceeds
the same way as the fixed point
induction we saw before
so in the first resolution round so to
speak
we can get x v and x w meaning in one
step we can reach
v and w and then in the second round of
resolution
then we can obtain an x t
and then we can get the empty clause as
well
uh and so in this case yeah
the clauses that we resolve um
appear in the same order as breadth
first search would do in this graph
and as the fixed point induction
proceeds so this example you see
um that somehow resolution directly
simulates fixed point iteration
um and now of course the question is
does this generally hold that you get
this nice correspondence
and the answer is yes but of course
it also depends on the encoding so we
should first of all say
how we translate this this graph
into a set of propositional clauses
so you see in this example the set of
propositional clauses
is structurally isomorphic to the graph
somehow so
you have propositional variables
corresponding to the vertices and the
edges correspond to these implication
clauses
so this translation is extremely simple
and that's somehow what we want in
general so
to make this more formal the way we we
translate arbitrary finite structures
to cnf formulas is via so-called first
order interpretations
and so if you don't know what this is it
suffices to think of it as
a first order definable mapping between
finance
structures so that means the elements of
the image structure
correspond to tuples of elements of the
original structure
and the relations in the image structure
are first order definable in the
original structure
and most importantly this means that um
computing this reduction given by such
an interpretation
does not require any computational
overhead so you don't need recursion or
fixed point induction
to compute this and that's why this is
somehow the natural choice of reduction
that we use here
um because we really want that this
fixed point iteration is simulated by
resolution
and not by the reduction that is in
between these two words
yeah so um the way how we simulate fixed
point formula in resolution
is we apply such an interpretation
to the input structure for the fixed
point formula
and uh this gives us a cnf formula that
we can use as the input for the proof
system
and of course this means that the cnf
formula is again represented as a graph
or
a finite structure but the concrete
representation is not relevant so this
is clear that this can be
done somehow okay and with respect to
this notion of reduction
uh we get all our correspondence
theorems between proof systems and
fixed point logics yeah so this is the
first result
um namely that lsp corresponds to
resolution on whole formulas
so in detail one direction is that for
every
fixed point sentence there is a first
order interpretation that just depends
on that sentence
which takes finite structures to own
formulas
such that the structure is a model of
the fixed point sentence
if and only if the whole formula that
you get is unsatisfiable
yeah so this shows indeed the evaluation
of fixed point formula formulas
can be done by resolution on home
formulas
and the proof for this goes um via
certain model checking games
for these fixed point logic so um yeah
i won't go too much into detail but one
can show or it is known that
on finance structures checking whether a
fixed point sentence is true
reduces to um solving so-called
reachability games
and this is very similar to the to the
example of the reachability problem that
i already showed you
um so in fact this can be encoded as a
whole formula and
that can be refuted in resolution
and the other direction is also true so
it's not so difficult to write down a
fixed point sentence
which exactly expresses that a whole
formula has a refutation
um because the complexity of horn
resolution is
quite low and um as i already said
this process of iteratively resolving
new causes
can be seen as a fixed point process
itself so
yeah this is why it's true and maybe
more interestingly
with the same reasoning you can also get
results for bounded width resolution
so this is the fragment of resolution
where the width of the course is bounded
by a constant
and this corresponds to a strict
fragment of
lfp called existential lfp
um this is uh like lfp but now the fixed
point formulas may not contain universal
quantifiers
and this is also known as stratified
data log by the way
um yeah and so this
weaker version of fixed point logic can
be simulated using only width 3
resolution and conversely for any k
width k resolution can also be expressed
in this fixed point logic again because
if the width of the clauses is at most
constant
then the proof size is guaranteed to be
polynomial because there are only
polynomially many
clauses you can resolve
okay yeah so this finishes the case of
resolution and now
we go one step further and
look at an algebraic proof system and
this means on the side of final model
theory that we add counting
so yeah albert has already talked about
this
um fixed point logic with counting is
simply the extension of lfp by so-called
counting terms
um yeah we won't go into the details but
essentially
this means you can now count the number
of satisfying assignments for formulas
um and the expressive power of this
logic
is between lfp and pe
so this is strictly stronger than lfp
because one can show that lsp cannot
count
and this is sort of the fix for that um
yeah
and the evaluation of these formulas is
still in p time
and yeah it's a fragment of p um
and one should say that from the point
of view final model theory this is um
an extremely well studied and important
logic
um so many combinatorial algorithms
can be expressed in this logic and
therefore it's
it's interesting to relate this to a
good system
um and the proof system that corresponds
to it is the polynomial calculus
and this is now not really a system for
for a propositional satisfiability
problem
but instead um the problem is this so
the input is always a set of polynomials
and they are multilinear so that means
they are multivariate polynomials but
each variable
has an exponent at most one
and the question is does there exist a
zero one assignment to the variables
that is a common zero of all these
polynomials
um so in this sense um it's also kind of
a propositional problem because
we treat the variables as propositional
variables in a sense
um and now there is a derivation
of the one polynomial from this input
polynomial set
if and only if this system of
polynomials is unsatisfiable
so meaning if there is no common zero
and so the proof rules are just these
two so
first of all you can take arbitrary
linear combinations of derived
polynomials
um here i should say that the
coefficients come from some
some field that you have to fix
beforehand so you can do this over
different fields and depending on the
field that you choose
you actually get a proof system with
different power
yeah but okay so this is the linear
combination rule and the second rule is
you may multiply any polynomial that you
have
with a variable from the variable set
and as an example let's say we have two
polynomials
x y minus one and x and you can see that
there is no common zero
because yeah if you have to set x to
zero
but then also x y is zero so the first
polynomial is then minus one
so there's no way to make them zero at
the same time
and therefore there should be a
derivation of the one polynomial
and this is easy in this case so um
first of all we can multiply
the input polynomial x with y then we
get x y
and then using the linear combination
rule we can
take x y and x y minus one and get the
one polynomial
yeah so in this case this works and this
also works in general so this is again a
sound and complete proof system
but again the size of the refutations is
what's interesting here so
quick question can you go back as well
can you go back one slide uh so the
variable x
with which you multiply the polynomial f
must
not already must not already appeared in
f is it
yeah you it usually should be um from
the input
i think you can also consider different
settings but uh yeah
here we consider only variables which
already appear in the input polynomials
would it not then give you like
quadratic
um if f contains x already would you not
get x squared
and i thought that was um yes i
didn't mention there's always implicitly
a rule which allows you to
which says something like um x squared
minus x equals zero
so you can always remove these um these
squares
with an extra proof rule that always
exists okay
yeah um
okay and so the complexity is either
again the size of a refutation
or um correspondingly to the width in
the case of a resolution
you can consider the maximum degree of
any polynomial
that you derive
and one can say also the characteristic
of the underlying field over which you
do all this
also affects the complexity so there are
sets of polynomials which are easy to
refute over
a certain finite field but require a
very large refutation of the rationals
for example
but in this setting we always consider
the rationals as the field
and one thing that is very important to
know is that
bounding the degree has an effect so
if we bound the degree by a constant
then all this becomes algorithmically
tractable
so you can exhaustively search for
proofs
in the k degree polynomial calculus in
polynomial time
and this is essentially due to linear
algebra so
the set of all derivative polynomials is
always the vector space
due to this linear combination rule and
so if the dimension of the vector space
is polynomial then
we can apply the so-called group my
basis algorithm to solve this
so the trick is that we don't have to
explicitly derive all polynomials that
we could derive
but we can always only consider the
basis of that space
and therefore this is tractable in p
time
and this is also part of the reason why
this theorem
holds that we got
yeah namely the polynomial calculus of
boundary degree corresponds
exactly to fpc so
on finite structures we can simulate any
fpc sentence
in the polynomial calculus over the
rationals already in degree
two and for any constant k we can also
exhaustively search for proofs in fpc
um again over the rationals
and yeah the proof so going from fpc to
the polynomial calculus is again by
model checking games
and these are now sort of reachability
games um
with counting so now not only the
existence of a winning strategy or of a
winning move is important
but also um the number of winning moves
that you have in a given position
um but these kinds of games can be
solved in the polynomial calculus if you
use
a suitable encoding and for the other
direction
i already said there exists this basis
algorithm
which exhaustively searches for proofs
and in case of the rationals we can
implement this in fpc
because yeah i think albert also
mentioned this that linear algebra over
over the rationals is somehow doable in
fpc
but for finite fields this is not
possible so this theorem really um is
only possible of the rationals
uh yeah so this is the overview of
results so we saw these three variants
of fixed point logic
in increasing expressive power and up to
these first order reductions they are um
equivalent to these proof systems and
what's maybe funny is that um
on the proof system side we considered
resolution and the polynomial calculus
which are two completely different
systems
but on the model theory side this just
corresponds to adding
the ability to count to fix point logic
so somehow
polynomial calculus is like resolution
with counting you could say
um okay so now
there's still this part about the lower
bounds so the main goal here was to
transfer
a well-known lower bounds from finite
model theory to proof complexity
and um so for this we still have to
specify how we measure complexity
in finite model theory and here we say
the complexity of a finite structure is
simply
the number of first order variables
required to identify the structure up to
isomorphism
and this is a bit sloppy but um
essentially
you can always ask yourself so what's
the least complex first order sentence
that
uniquely describes the structure
and with this complexity measure you can
also write two structures
a and b are k equivalent if they cannot
be distinguished by any k variable
sentence
where sentence refers to fixed point
logic now
or also first order logic
and the idea is that if we have um two
structures for which we can prove that
they are sufficiently similar
so k equivalent then this also carries
over to the
corresponding um propositional formulas
that we get
using in this old interpretation so then
also in k
width resolution or k degree polynomial
calculus
the corresponding formulas are
indistinguishable so either they both
have a refutation or both don't have a
refutation
now because if they were somehow
distinguishable
in the proof system then using these
simulation results um
it would follow that they are also
distinguishable in fixed point logic
but this is not the case um you know so
this is the the argument here
and maybe the main example for that we
got lower bounds for
or reproved lower bounds for um is the
graph isomorphism problem
um so here you can exploit yeah standard
constructions from finite model theory
so the so-called cfi construction which
we can read as a black box now
but it yields sequences of yeah
non-isomorphic graphs of increasing size
but the fact that they are not
isomorphic is very hard to tell from the
point of view of logic so
they require a linear number of
variables to be distinguished in fixed
point logic
and if we use these graphs and take any
interpretation that maps them
so maps pairs of graphs to propositional
formulas that express the existence of
an isomorphism
then using the reasoning that i already
mentioned we can infer that
the width or the degree that is required
to refute
the corresponding isomorphism
formula is at least linear because
otherwise
if it were a sublinear then these
structures could also be distinguished
in fixed point logic
with a sublinear number of variables and
from this one immediately gets that the
size of the proofs is at least
exponential because
this is a well-known relationship from
proof complexity that
the size of a proof is uh always
exponential in the
in the width or the degree um
yeah and all this is not you so these
things
had already been known these lower
bounds um but now we have this yeah
unifying framework for proving them and
also this is more independent of the
encoding of the graph isomorphism
problem because
our results hold for any encoding up to
first order interpretations
and lastly one can say that also other
lower bounds from proof complexity can
be reapproved
using these methods so for example
well-known exponential lower bounds for
resolution
for pigeonhole principle and the three
colorability problem for graphs
um yeah can also be now inferred from
finite model theory
yeah so that's it thank you benedict for
a fantastic talk
thank you questions please so for
pigeonhole and three colorability you
can't get anything for
uh that would translate into polynomial
calculus lower bounds
um i don't think that we did this but
uh that should probably also work yes
other questions pablo i have a question
please yeah i have a question vijay yeah
please go ahead
so albert and with focus and i have
looked at defined something called
csp proofs consent satisfaction proofs
and in some sense the closing to file
model fury because you're really working
more directly with relations there
and you could define the notion of
bounded with proof which
i don't know if i don't think we define
it but you could define easily define
the quantum
of a bonded with proof there
and would be interesting to see how i
don't think so the relationship there
again to
to lfp has not been worked but it will
be interesting to see how it fits in
this picture
okay so what do you mean i think i'm not
aware of this work
i'll i'll send you a pointer later yeah
okay thank you
yeah there are two questions in the chat
uh antonina asked the question in the
paper you mentioned a normal form
for the structure used in the last proof
could you say a bit about it
[Music]
um
um wait which normal thing i think
uh antonin are you referring to the uh
you can unmute yourself and ask the
question but are you referring to the
graphic isomorphism
i think to remember that in one of the
proofs you define
the norm uh
operating you talk about normal forms of
the structure
and that allows you to get around the
cfi construction
and um i was i found it very interesting
that you could say something about it
that would be
great um
has a question is there a relationship
between
the resolution width and the arity fixed
point operators in here
well there's certainly a relationship
between the number of first order
variables that you use in this formula
but
between the arity yes probably
probably two because i mean the arity of
these
fixed point um operators somehow
corresponds to the
to the resolution with in the in the
natural way
when you simulate it um but
i don't know if you can um formally show
this
uh you know igor oliveira asked is there
any hope
lots of questions actually she hope that
stronger proof systems can be captured
in this way
um beyond yeah so i tried this um
to extend this to um
so i don't know if you know the logic
choices polynomial time so
that's another extension of fixed point
logic with counting which is
um strictly stronger and i tried whether
this logic can also be captured by a
proof system in this way
but that only worked in one direction so
in the proof system that
somehow corresponds to this is um
extended polynomial calculus so that's a
version of polynomial calculus where
still the degree is bounded by a
constant
but you may use extra variables in the
proof to abbreviate um high degree
polynomials
in some sense and that's a stronger
improved system but
it does not um correspond to the choices
polynomial time in both directions
so i don't know if this nice
correspondence really works for
for stronger proof systems as well no
maybe not a couple of more questions so
massimo lauria asks
there is a map from width key resolution
to lfp and
llfp llfp2 with three resolution
but width 3 is weaker than width k is
there something going on in the encoding
similarly for the polynomial calculus um
yeah this is because the encoding is um
yeah via these first order
identifications
and so basically this width
gap is somehow hidden in the
in yeah in the reduction between um
going back and forth between finance
structures and these
encodings um so the first order
interpretation basically
does the bridges the gap between the
width
thomas uh cochman asks uh you mentioned
on set how about on sat which is p
complete
the left p simulates on unset and lfp is
strictly weaker than p so horn on sat is
strictly weaker than onsite
um wait aren't horn answered and horns
are the same
yeah i don't think i can answer this
directly sorry
um
pavel has the question how do you prove
the lower bound on the pigeonhole
principle
formulas the formula has large width
um yeah you take structures
which so you take some audit structures
which essentially encode
the pigeonhole principle um
and then you have to show that
the structure that corresponds to
mapping n pigeons to n holes
and the structure that corresponds to
mapping n plus one pigeons to n holes
that these structures cannot be
distinguished using less than n
variables in first order logic
okay but what i don't understand is
you said that you use width and degree
to get the
size lower balance so in the case of
the of the general principle
uh you cannot do it directly
because the the width of the formula
itself is already
large right right that's true oh
okay oh yeah i see what you mean um
okay then i would have to check that
again uh if that's even i'm correct
quick question benedict were you able to
prove any new
lower bonds that were not previously
known like new classes of formulas
um no so at least not so far
is there any law
is there any lower bound infinite model
for random structure
what would random structure mean though
i would really like to get such lower
bounds for pc
uh i can approve myself yes go ahead
please
i mean uh i
for example we know for a lower bound
for tricolor ability
for resolution of random graphs
we don't know lower bound for tricolor
ability
for a random graph we only know for uh
uh specific worst case constructions
so uh if we could prove
a lower bound for tricolor ability over
random graphs
for example in the fpc
then i i would understand that we would
get a lower bound
for rand for random graph in polynomial
characters
ah yes um i mean i haven't looked at
this but
um this might be worthwhile to think
about then
so you're saying um there is no known
lower bound for random graphs
for three colorability for the
polynomial calculus or
no only for resolution i mean the
tricolor ability k
color i i i don't know the number
precisely but
if you take a random graph around or
around on the regular graph that would
be
hard the first sort of uh
d over log d colors i mean you you have
to
basically choose the number precisely
but somehow you have hard instances for
tricolor ability
if you take a random irregular graph for
the right value of the
say okay so yeah
if one counts such graphs in the
resolution we know
we know these lower bounds but we don't
know them for uh polynomial calculus
okay so maybe it would be a way to go to
try and find such graphs that that are
hard to distinguish in fixed point logic
it's cool thanks for that question
massimo all right
uh thank you again benedick for a great
talk and oh
albert you have a question please go
ahead just a comment on the random graph
thing but
usually random graphs tend to be rigid
and they don't have automorphisms
and therefore and even what tends to
happen is that you can define a linear
order on them
with the logic and then the lower bounds
tend to break
on the other hand there is a
construction known as the multi-pitch
construction
which is a random construction
and it gives lower bounds for fpc
so this is this is due to gravity
chinchilla
and it has not been yeah
it's something to look at i know exactly
why you're asking this machine and i
think it's a good question yeah
thank you again uh thanks for a great
talk benedict